people are starting to panic and 2020 is
not looking like a great year for
developers the Dow was down over 2,000
points today and has been collapsing for
the last few weeks VCS are warning
founders to preserve cash all the big
tech conferences have been canceled
governments are talking about helicopter
cash and 0% interest rates and things
are deteriorating very quickly out there
in today's video we'll look at why and
more importantly what does it mean for
software developers in the future
everything we see in the headlines is
about coronavirus but we can't blame
everything on this virus the global
economy and the tech industry in
particular has been in a nearly non-stop
bull market for the last 10 years some
might even call it a bubble if we go
back to the early 2010's many of the big
public companies that we know today were
just starting to raise money from
private VCS
the successful startups always had
access to a huge amount of cash and were
able to focus on growth while operating
deep in the red or in other words not
make a profit for a really long time or
in most cases never make a profit around
2016 a lot of these VC funded startups
started to go public one of my favorite
examples is Shopify an IPO in 2015 at
$28 in 2020 it's traded well above $500
per share now the company's revenue has
grown significantly but so of expenses
and it's still not profitable today but
its market value has increased 20 times
on speculation and optimism and there
are many other tech companies in a
similar situation they continue to burn
through cash and are a long way from
profitability which is how you generate
new cash on your own without external
financing now I'm sure Shopify will turn
out just fine but there are plenty of
smaller companies out there with shorter
runways that may not be able to survive
a severe cash crunch Sequoia Capital one
of the most well-known VCS in Silicon
Valley released this black swan memo to
its founders I recommend reading the
whole thing on your own but basically it
boils down to a warning that companies
may not be able to burn through cash
like they have in the past and what's
one of the first things companies do
when they start to run out of cash well
they start laying people off employees
are very valuable but they're also very
expensive and at the end of the day cash
is king
when you run out of money the game is
over now at this point it's impossible
to predict if the stock market will
continue to fall but layoffs always lag
behind the activity in the stock market
during the last financial crisis the
jobless rate didn't start to rise until
well after the stock market had bottomed
out on top of that we've already seen
cost-cutting and downsizing among some
of the big tech unicorns so what does
all this mean for professional software
developers if you have a job today
great it's probably a good idea to
hold on to that job until you have
something better lined out if the
companies that have the best developer
jobs are cost-cutting it means there
will be fewer developer jobs going
around and it may drive down the value
of compensation and I would expect that
to have the biggest impact on junior
developer roles because we have a lot
more talent entering the industry
through things like coding boot camps
not to mention these coding boot camps
have been receiving a lot of criticism
lately primarily because of already poor
job placement rates and that will only
get worse in a bad economy it really
just comes down to supply and demand
more talent and fewer jobs means less
money per job furthermore if you're
taking stock options as compensation
your ability to get rich off those
options is far less likely in a bear
market taking equity as compensation is
far more risky for you than it is for
the founders offering you that equity so
just something to keep in mind now if
you're a software developer building a
product getting VC funding for that
product may be more difficult in the
future my personal philosophy is to
focus on building a profitable product
right from the beginning when you're not
dependent on external funding like a
bank or a VC you're much more likely to
survive economic swings now what if
you're just learning how to code should
you even bother well in my case I'm
passionate about building software I
enjoy the process of identifying
problems and then writing the solutions
and code to solve those problems even if
things continue falling it's still a
great skill to have
and will continue being the source of
many high-paying jobs in the future so
here's my interpretation of what's going
on we have this awesome tech industry
but maybe we've been a little
overzealous the coronavirus not really a
huge deal on its own is a catalyst
popping the bubble now when things start
to go down in a panic they go down a lot
faster than they did on their way up and
then economic realities start to set in
companies with poor cash flow will have
to go to extreme measures just to
survive now I just want to finish things
off by reminding you that I might be
completely wrong this whole thing might
just blow over in a week or two or maybe
Donald Trump in the Fed will step in and
save everybody I mostly just wanted to
provide a worst-case scenario type of
outlook in fact economic declines tend
to be a good thing long-term they create
a lot of opportunity for developers and
entrepreneurs and the painful parts tend
to be short-lived I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap things up there and tomorrow I will
be back with a regular code tutorial
thanks for watching like and subscribe
and I will see you in the next one